but we walked out of the spider room and
we went to
uh puppy adoption because i said maybe
i'll get a puppy an animal shelter
an animal shelter which i gotta be
honest
and this is a little controversial i
hear and i don't uh uh i i i it's
i know that it's to help them and i want
everyone to get help
but it is not a real fun way
to get a [ __ ] dog is it can we be
honest
these dogs are homeless they're like
four years old they're not puppies
the people that are showing you the dogs
also look like they need a fair amount
of help
i mean it's just bad
and you sit there and they bring the dog
out and it's very sad because they
brought out a husky and
the husky's family returned them because
he was getting territorial with a baby
and uh they didn't have the time you
know people in la are so goddamn selfish
they didn't have the time to throw a
frisbee with the poor husky so they
brought him back it's [ __ ] tragic
isn't it really sad it's very sad and
then they brought out a shepherd before
the husky and he and again
they're beautiful dogs but they're aloof
and you could tell they've been through
it a little yeah
they've been through it a little you
know i tend to think a lady in the [ __ ]
you know where they come out of the like
a nice box and they pop
out on christmas morning you know
they bring out these like damaged
skittish
dogs and
and i i immediately try to be a little
funny which they don't like humor they
hate humor these people
she goes what are the important
qualities of a dog and i said one that
can swallow the most
cocaine that's funny
what's wrong with her this woman gives
me a look
i said i'm kidding i'm a comedian she
goes oh
i'm just joking but i don't have the
time to devote to a puppy and it's sad
and um because i will here's the thing
about me i
know this is why i can't adopt anything
i will bring it back
like i'm the guy that brings it right
back
i'll bring it right back first sign of a
problem
i mean literally the first
sign of a problem i will show up and
they know that about me which is why
they make every dog sound horrible
every dog because they look at me they
go he's the guy that brings it back
dude every dog they were like it might
kill a baby i'm like i didn't even ask
that
they just don't want me to adopt it
because they know like the first sign of
trouble
i'm like you're out of here i'll just
he's back they'll be like you had him
for six hours i'm like
the dog went crazy he got into something
but it's sad uh that
there are so many dogs out there
and they're not cared for but i can't
take on the responsibility
of having a dog unless i have the time
and i'm gonna travel
a lot coming up we have new dates on the
road uh all over the place we're in uh
pennsylvania and baltimore maryland and
we are in
uh chicago and we're in um
austin and we're in a bunch of other
places and the dates are on the website
and
the website's getting redone so we're
putting stuff
we're putting stuff up uh little by
little we're trying to get everything
out there but
uh we're gonna be on the road so i don't
have the time to really deal with a dog
i don't have the time to really devote
myself
to an animal and i gotta be honest with
you
this is gonna sound horrible and i hate
admitting this
i want a purebred puppy
who's very cute and very happy
do you see what i mean is that
controversial to say
no but some people would just get mad if
then you went to like a puppy mill
or something like what is a puppy mill
you know where they make the
dogs you know they the dogs die
they're they're all inbred it's not good
it's really not
good so you go to a breeder yeah yeah
yeah
they're breeding dogs they're using them
to to make money off of them
but a lot of time the living conditions
aren't that good and there's so many
dogs that need homes anyway like and
purebred dogs
you're against the purebred you think
you people should just get rescues
probably but they're they're losers
the rescues i mean let's be very honest
well
they're and you don't want them around
your children because many of them will
attack your children
that's true this is true if they were
beaten and they were
homeless and you know then yeah no good
i think they should make up lies about
where the dogs were because the woman
was like we don't know where this dog
came from i'm like just make it up
just make up a lie about where it came
from that makes me want to adopt this
dog
right but i want a like a purebred
puppy that's from a breeder who's you
know
i get it i totally get it they they have
a lot of problems they don't live very
long
the purebred yeah yeah perfect
that probably describes me i want
a dog that i can
have fun with for a few years and then
i mean how long is your three-legged do
you have a three-legged dog how old is
it
emma is nine now yeah she's old isn't
that insane
yeah i think she'll live till she's like
13. but that's absurd yeah to me i get a
purebred st bernard eight years
i'm just saying i'm not trying to you
know
i just really want a dog but i don't
want to really take care of it and i
don't want one of these
mixed breed homeless
baby killers which is
rescue dogs i believe are
homeless baby killers of
of uncertain origin and i'm just
wondering why you'd bring that into your
home
i don't know i know adoptions are way up
during kovitz that's been good
less animals going to kill shelters what
is the kill shelter i find this
interesting
i believe there's a certain amount of
time the dog can be in one of these
shelters before then it just gets
executed
so if no one wants it after a certain
amount of time they got to make room for
more and then it's just
gone it's a dark job yeah working in a
dog kill shelter
yeah who does that
god that's tough that is tough that's a
tough job yeah
i'm i still don't want the rescues in my
home
even though it is a tough job i still
think that
is it is it should we
and i'm not trying again should we maybe
outlaw
rescuing dogs
[Laughter]
because it's too much of a risk do you
know what i mean
in terms of it killing people and babies
yeah and just not not looking
good and everything should we maybe
not allow people to adopt
should they go right to the kill shelter
i might ask questions i don't really
know you're more of a dog person i love
dogs
but i just want to understand the way
this is all supposed to work
so if your dog gets lost and animal
control gets it it should just go right
to the kill shelter
essentially wow i mean
loss is interesting i mean it has
information on it it can be returned
if it has a chip in it they scan it well
but it does have a
does it have a collar where it says it's
going yeah yeah yeah okay so why would
they do
you don't need to put that dog in a kill
shot you could return it to its owner
yeah animal control takes it to an
animal shelter and then calls
you and says you have to pick it up and
you have to pay money to get it out
i've done that before okay
well that then that dog clearly doesn't
have to go to a kill shelter right
but any dog that gets lost without a
collar or a chip should go to the kill
shelter is what you're saying
i'm saying this
this is what i'm saying yeah
i think dogs
that haven't made the right
choices
should have to take responsibility
i'm not i'm saying
when you're rescuing a dog you're
adopting
a homeless
mentally ill baby killer and you're
bringing it into your home
when you go to a breeder and you get a
purebred animal
you're getting a dog of what has a
lineage
maybe their mother or father was a show
dog and you spend money
you spend thousands of dollars and when
you spend thousands of dollars on
something
it's better and you take it more
seriously
right yeah that's a good point so i
think
the problem is the animal shelters are
actually the problem because they allow
the reason that you have homeless dogs
is because you have animal shelters
do you understand what dude let's walk
this out
homeless i don't see a flaw here
i really don't you got this whole
thriving business of people
selling homeless pets they're slinging
homeless dog go with me on this folks
they got these people in the shelters
slinging these drug mules that they find
wandering around parking lots shut it
down
shut it down yes or yes shut it down
have the only people that should get
dogs are people who can afford
to pay thousands of dollars to a breeder
for a purebred and yes it has health
problems
but that's also good
to assess how serious you are about
owning a dog because yes you're gonna
get a purebred dog and you're gonna have
to take it to the hospital all the time
and that means you're serious about
owning a dog if you go adopt a homeless
baby killer
from one of these uh you know one of
these [ __ ]
animal drug mule animal shelters
you're like okay i just have this and
then what it's going to become a mud
again
yeah true i just am against rescuing
dogs
i've always been against it
i don't know why that's a controversial
position
it seems like it is propping up a
system
that is really
terrible for both the animals and the
people
why are these all these stray dogs
around
why because
of the whole the homeless dog shelter
that makes money they get money from the
state these people
it's true the humane society they get
money from the state
and dog and cats i'm including cats
should never
be cats should survive on the streets
they should never be taken into a
shelter i agree
cats are capable they were gods cats
were gods
at one time in egypt true
and now they're taken into these
shelters
it's not right i don't think it's right
i think if you want a dog you should
take it seriously
and not rescue a dog and go to a
go to a breeder and deal with a breeder
if you if you actually take it seriously
i believe if you rescue a dog it says
something negative about you
you have a god complex
[Laughter]
you wanna you're trying to [ __ ] it
you're maybe trying to [ __ ] the animal
is that what you're trying to do
supposedly a lot of people are
you said that you said you didn't you
say that a lot of people trying to [ __ ]
lizards now
right how do you find these things you
said people trying to [ __ ] anacondas
uh snakes yeah there was a video that
went viral on twitter a couple years ago
of a guy
going at it with a snake in the egg hole
like just holding it up like that be
honest was it hot
no it was strange it was bizarre but you
can't not
you can't look away you it's if it's a
10-second thing you watch it you know
there's one on twitter of a guy having
sex with a fish too like a carp
that went kind of viral how often do you
watch people have sex with animals
i mean those are really like the two
times so you've
stumbled upon stumbled upon yeah
i've never played them on the show no we
can't why
we'd get thrown off youtube for playing
a man having sex with a carp
it's bestiality indeed
interesting that does seem like we would
we would be removed but how funny would
it be removed
like you're just in a room of canceled
people and they're like how did you
how did you get de-platformed some guy's
like hey man i just tweeted a lot of q
and on [ __ ]
another guy's like you know i just was
retweeting all these crazy accounts or
making racist jokes and
i'm like bestiality
the old-fashioned way watching a guy
[ __ ] a snake
but it fascinates you when people have
sex with things they're not supposed to
yeah it is interesting it's odd
something went wrong in that guy's head
yeah wires got crossed something
happened
but do you not understand that those are
the type of people that are rescuing
dogs
those people it's kind of true
absolutely is true
yeah all the people that work in the
shelter were sick people
um let's be very honest i kid a lot
about this
on i kid around a lot here because i'm a
comedian but i'm not kidding around
about this
i think if you rescue a dog
you are you are engaging in
bestiality what is the name for
somebody who engages in bestiality
obviously see if there's a singular
what what is the name for somebody
someone
who engages in bestiality
um let's see now we're on reddit so god
help us
oh zoo a file zoo file yeah
you're a zoo file
what a horrible lesson to teach your
children taking them to a homeless
shelter
to adopt some mutt what a horrible
lesson
to teach your children to say we're
going to go to the
shelter and pick up some dirty rat
to bring home what a beautiful lesson to
go to a breeder
and see a bunch of puppies in a field
and say i'm spending
a lot of [ __ ] money for this dog you
better [ __ ]
knock it out of the park with the with
the uh kill with the um
homeless shelter the animal shelters
it's easy come easy go
easy come easy go that's why they bring
these things back
because it's easy companies you go dogs
should cost thousands of dollars
um they should
get mad at me if you want but if you
have a dog and you're young
you're not serious about succeeding it
if you really want to succeed and you
have a very difficult career
and you have a dog and you've adopted a
dog i know you're not serious about
succeeding
truth just reality i know people that
are
sweet people but they go i have a dog
and it depends on what your career is
but
if you really want to light the world on
fire you're really trying to do well
and you uh have decided that it's more
important to have a dog
um you know you're you're not you're
letting things get in your way
you're letting things get in your way
which is fine but
just admit that to yourself so many
people i talk to like man i want to do
this i want to do that but then they
have a dog and i'm like dude you have a
dog
that's crazy you you you weigh yourself
down
with things like that and it just shows
that you don't have a um
you don't understand that time is so
valuable that's the problem you just
can't be
you know so
i had six dogs before i
did the rogan show and i and i
afterwards it went well and i took them
all to kill shelter
four of them went to kill shelter two of
them i drowned in the bathtub myself
just because i then started selling
tickets and i needed to
you understand